welcome to the live session where we'll
go over
chapter two of the akinsis course i'm
joined by lewis with on the chat and
we're going to answer
all your questions quicker than i will
and don't hesitate
to ask all your questions because i'm
going to read them a lot and answer them
on the live stream that's like the main
advantage of following this live stream
instead of just watching the course by
yourself
um so over in inside this chapter 2
we'll look at the pipeline object that
we
used at length during chapter 1 on all
nlp tasks
and we'll see exactly how it works we'll
see how it loads the model uh
how it reprocesses the inputs with a
tokenizer
and then how it post processes those
outputs
to get the predictions and probabilities
that we got
during chapter one um
so we'll watch a few videos i'll answer
all the questions that you have and
we'll do
more live coding than in chapter one
because um
[Music]
because chapter one was just a general
introduction and there is a lot of more
code in chapter two
so as an introduction as you may know
again face is mainly known for its
transformers library
which is a library containing a lot of
transformers models
and it provides an easy api
to download pre-trained model and to use
the different architectures i think
there are more than 60 architectures now
available in the library and
it all exposes a unified api but inside
and provides you with either a torch
module
or a tensorflow keras model that you can
use
by yourself or that you can
train with the api that the library also
provides
and the the the goal is so ease of use
flexibility
and simplicity and the library doesn't
contain any abstraction
at all it's not a library composed of
building blocks
every model every one of the 60
architectures i was talking about
is completely defined in its all in its
own
modeling files so we can have a quick
look for instance
at the modeling bert file which contains
all the code
of the birth model inside the library as
if you look at the import
you see like there are just torch
imports and then some
internal classes that this uses but
which are sharp
between all models which are mainly uh
the output
types that we use we'll see exactly what
those outputs are a little bit later
when we code
but there is no other imports there is
not like an attention block
that will reuse the quest model the
attention block for the broad model is
defined inside this modeling file
so we have the burton buildings you have
the bird self attention
etc etc and the idea is that if you want
to play around with the model
and change a line of code inside the
model you won't have to learn
50 different files and it's not
subclassing something that's a classic
something but super classic something
everything oh i'm guessing i'm just
realizing i'm
hiding a bit it's okay i guess i'm just
going to scroll faster
you have everything in that modeling
bird file and you can play around and
modify everything you want
if you want to experiment with it and
that's really one of the strengths of
the transformers library
one of the features that our users have
said they like a lot
which is why i wanted to show it to you
briefly
and um so yeah we'll see
how the pipeline api loads that birth
model it was actually a distilbert model
that we used in chapter one
and the corresponding tokenizer and how
to do everything that
this pipeline function was doing by hand
so that you can tweak
any of the steps if you need to on your
own tasks so let's begin
with the first section and the first
video we're gonna watch this
introductory video that's gonna present
what's happening with being behind the
pipeline
i'm just not gonna stream them from
youtube because
that's making the live stream lag a lot
i'm just i have all the videos locally
so if you give me just one minute
i'm gonna extract it and
play it from my computer
[Music]
what happens inside the pipeline
function
in this video we'll look at what
actually happens when we use the
pipeline function of the transformers
library
more specifically we'll look at the
sentiment analysis pipeline
and how it went from the two following
sentences to the positive
and negative labels with our respective
scores
as we've seen in the pipeline
presentation there are three stages in
the pipeline
first we convert the row text to numbers
the model can make sense of
using a tokenizer then those numbers go
through the model which outputs the kits
finally the post-processing steps
transform those delegates into labels
and scores
let's look in details at those three
steps and how to replicate them using
the transformers library
beginning with the first stage
tokenization
the tokenization process has several
steps first
the text is split into small chunks
called tokens
they can be words part of words or
punctuation symbols
then the tokenizer will add some special
tokens if the model
expects that here the model used expect
a cls token at the beginning
and a step token at the end of the
sentence to classify
lastly the tokenizer matches each token
to its unique id
in the vocabulary of the pre-trained
model to load such a tokenizer
the transformers library provides the
auto-tokenizer api
the most important method of this class
is from pre-trained
which will download and cache the
configuration and the vocabulary
associated to a given checkpoint here
the checkpoint used by default for the
sentiment analyzes pipeline
is distilled based on case film tuned
ss2 english
which is a bit of a mouthful we
instantiate a tokenizer associated with
a checkpoint
then feed it to the two sentences since
the two sentences are not of the same
size
we'll need to pad the shortest one to be
able to build an array
this is done by the tokenizer with the
option padding equal to
with truncation equal true we ensure
that any sentence longer than the
maximum the model can handle
is truncated lastly the return sensors
option
tells the tokenizer to return the
pytorch tensor
looking at the result we see we have a
dictionary with two keys
input ids contain the ids of both
sentences
with zero where the padding is applied
the second key
attention mask indicates where padding
has been applied so the model does not
pay attention to it
this is all what is inside the
tokenization step now let's have a look
at the second step
the model as for the tokenizer
there is an auto model api with a form
retrain method
it will download and cache the
configuration of the module as well as
the pre-trained weight
however the auto model api will only
instantiate the body of the model
that is the part of the model that is
left once the protraining head is
removed
it will output a high dimensional tensor
that is a representation of the
sentences passed
but which is not directly useful for a
classification problem
here the tensor has two sentences each
of 16 tokens
and the last dimension is the indent
size of our model 768.
to get an output link to our
classification problem we need to use
the auto model for sequence
classification class
it works exactly as the auto model class
except that it will build a model with a
classification head
there is one auto class for each common
nlp task in the transformers library
here after giving our model the two
sentences
we get a tensor of size two by two one
result for each sentence
and for each possible label those
outputs are not probabilities yet
we can see they don't sum to one this is
because each model of the transformers
library
returns logins to make sense of those
logits we need to dig into the third
and last step of the pipeline post
processing
to convert logits into probabilities we
need to apply a softmax layers to them
as we can see this transforms them into
positive number
that's them up to one the last step is
to know which of those correspond to the
positive or the negative level
this is given by the id to label field
of the model config the first
probabilities
index 0 correspond to the negative label
and the seconds
index y correspond to the positive level
this is how our classifier built with
the pipeline function picked those
labels
and completed those scores now that you
know how each step works
you can easily trick them to your needs
and
i am back
and
i think that's something
wrong with as a webcam let me just
double check
um okay so somehow my head disappeared
i don't know why exactly if you can see
it feel free to say it in the chat
[Music]
in the meantime there is a question uh
what does the triple that signify in
from
the activations import act to function
in the py files shown uh very good
question
so this is standard python if you are
building
a package in python and you're trying
to import things
you have several levels so it's because
of the structure of the transformer repo
let me try to pull it back and quit my
vs code
but
here we are so you have the transformers
uh
folder and then inside the transformer
models you have a models subfolder
and then a bird subfolder and then the
modeling file is here
and since we've organized the code that
way to avoid having all the files
directly in the transformers folder
because as i said we have like 60
different architectures so that would be
a lot of files
they are organized like this and when
you're trying to import
when you say from dot dot dot it's to go
back uh
inside the structure so from that uh
import blah blah blah would be in the
bird folder that that is in the models
fold folder
and then the dot that that gets back to
the transformers
folder so it's just a way to come back
to the root
of the of the directory um
i've done i didn't see any other
questions but don't hesitate to ask at
any time in the chat your questions and
our own server
as best as i can and as i expected my
webcam is not showing anymore and i have
no idea why
because
i just
shoot the video i know it's not working
let me just write something
here we are sorry about that i had to
just shut it down and restart it
so uh we're good to continue uh behind
uh our expression behind the pipeline
function and so we'll we'll just take a
little bit of the code that we just saw
in the video i'm not going to show it
from the section side but remember that
in most sections in all the sections
that i've code you have
an open and collab button at the top
like this which i opened a little bit
earlier
just to execute the first cell which is
installing everything and can take a bit
of time
and then the second cell which is
downloaded the model uh
i executed it already so that we have
the result
instantaneously here and we are ready to
look at the rest of the notebook
so like in the video let me
move myself on the other side of the
screen because
the code is mostly
on the left
so like in the video we'll look exactly
at the code that is executed
when we try to use the sentiment
analysis pipeline
on two sentences uh like that and see
how
we get to the results on those labels
so as we've seen in the video the first
step of the pre-processing
is done by by a tokenizer so we'll
we'll look into uh the tokenizers in
detail a little bit further ahead
but uh for not just you just need to
know that the tokenizer takes
the input text so those two sentences
i've been waiting for the early phase
course my whole life and i ate it so
much
it's gonna take those two sentences and
convert that them into numbers because
the model doesn't understand texts
it understands numbers so basically
behind the scenes
it's going to split that text into small
chunks that we call token
and so on tokenizer and then associate
each of us token to a unique id which is
the numbers
that we're going to see to load the
tokenizer we need to know the identifier
of the tokenizer
so here this is the identifier of the
of the model that is used by sentiment
analysis pipeline by default
and then we just call autotokenizer.form
pretrained
and it's gonna download
uh if you if the file's already
downloaded because i executed this first
but
if it's the first time you're executing
this it's gonna download the files of
the tokenizer
and in particular the vocabulary which
contains the mapping token to unique id
and instantiate it and once you have
that object available you can feed it
your input directly like this so raw
input inside
tokenizer and we'll exactly explain what
force padding and truncation mean
a little bit further ahead and we tell
it to return 10 source and since we're
using pi torch here
we tell it to restart a pi torch
transfer with this pt
you can also say tf of tensorflow
tensors
np for numpy arrays or flags for
flax which is i guess for flex it's also
done by the arrays
and if we execute it we can see that we
get
an output which is a dictionary with
input ids and
attention mask we'll explain what the
attention mask means
a little bit forward in the course
in this live session sorry and the input
ids are the unique numbers i was talking
about so
it's converted that text into small
chunks of
that are called tokens and each of the
stockings have been associated to unique
number
and once we have that we can use
the model on this input
just if we want to have a look back
why are you annoying me um if we want to
have a look back
at how those ids correspond to the
the text that we had at the beginning we
can use the decode method method of our
tokenizer
so if i type tokenizer.decode
[Music]
and then i'm take my inputs
grab the key input ids
[Music]
tick tick like this
so this is a tensor so i'm going to
convert it to a list
and take this is a list of lists because
i have two
uh the two sentences in my sentence in
my tensor sorry so i'm
just taking the first one for instance
and if i executed that
you execute that sorry i can see my
original text
which has been a bit pre-processed there
is no
capital anymore for the eye for instance
and we can also see that the tokenizer
added
something at the beginning and something
at the end this is perfectly logical
as the tokenizer is adding those um
the tokenizer is adding those tokens uh
because the model expects them
so i'm just gonna pause here for
questions before i go into the model
part of the code
what does auto in auto tokenizer mean
and what type of tokenizer is used so
the auto for auto tokenizer mean as in
the auto technology class
means that you can load any tokenizer
corresponding to any architecture
using that api so for instance here our
model is a distilbert model
so the tokenizer is going to be a
distilled tokenizer
you can double check that by just adding
a console
if i type tokenizer
and print the output it's going to tell
me
it's a pretend tokenizer fast which is
not super useful
[Music]
but the representation is not super
useful but the type
should be a distilled tokenizer fast
um and if i had used a
bird checkpoint i would have a bird
tokenizer fast if i had used i don't
know a bart checkpoint i would have a
bar tokenizer first etc etc
so the auto in auto tokenizer means that
that class is going to pick
the right subclass of tokenizer so when
corresponding to
the model used by your checkpoint
automatically
so your code here tokenizer equals
autotokenizer.from pre-trained
checkpoint
is gonna work from for any checkpoint on
the on the model up
whatever the class of your model as long
as it's a class of model that's been
implemented in transformers it's going
to work on it
uh whereas if you were using here
distilbert organizer you would have to
change
the class used if you change the type of
checkpoint for instance if you use the
bert model you would have to change it
to burt organizer
if you were using a gpt2 checkpoint you
would need to change it to gpt2
tokenizer etc etc
um
the second question was will i'm be
broken
into i and am and the answer of
to that is uh yes we'll see a little bit
i'm
just going to pose an answer more
completely a little bit later when we
see exactly the different type of
tokenizers
and what is the difference between a
fast organizer and a standard tokenizer
very good question so we usually have
4-h model 2 tokenizers
one that is called slow or standard
and the other that is called fast the
fast organizer is backed by
the looking face tokenizers library
which is
not written in python but in rust and
which in turn
because you may have known that python
is a slow language
and so if you do the world tokenization
in pure python
it can be a bit slow when you have lots
lots of text
whereas the tokenizer fast backed by
rust is going to be
extremely fast so the main difference uh
that's the main difference between the
two of them if you are just processing
one text you won't see any difference
but if you're processing ten thousands
of text at the same time
as the token tokenizer fast is going to
be much faster than the python tokenizer
and that's also a question we have for
the moment so i'm going to continue
and look at the model
so the same way we have a new tokenizer
api we have an auto model api
and again the auto in auto model api
means that the this class is going to
pick
the right subclass bert model gpd2 model
distilbert model etc
depending on the checkpoint that it
receives so here
since it's a distributor checkpoint it's
gonna
output a distilled model i can just show
you
here by typing model and it should
have a nice wrap we can see here this
steel bird model
um i'm gonna remove
that cell because it's a bit annoying
thank you for not
um so that model
is coming with uh again
uh we didn't download any file here
because when we executed the pipeline
instruction at the very beginning um we
downloaded everything we needed so the
model is already cached
that's why we don't see any download
here and we get a warning
which i'm going to explain just after
this cell
which is because this auto model class
is going to give us the base
pre-trained model and this space
pre-trained model
doesn't output a classification
of our sentence between positive and
negative it outputs the hidden state
of the pre-trained model which is of
dimension 768.
so that's why here we have a warning
because that model of the model is
missing a classification head
and as the warning was saying
some weights of the checkpoint were not
used when initializing the model
specifically classifier bias let's fire
weights etc extra
which has which are all the weights of
the classifier head
um so auto model is something that can
be useful if you just want
the tensor of hidden features outputted
by your pretend model
but here we want to classify our
sentences
between positive and negative so we need
a model with a classification head
and that's given to us with it by the
auto model for sequence classification
class
and this one when i execute the cell is
not going to output any warning because
all the weights
are going to be used and there is not
going to be anything problematic when
you dig the checkpoint
and if we give our input to that model
and look at the shape and we can see
that it's going to be
a transfer of size 2 by 2. one little
comment about
the output is that the output of
transformer models so that was the thing
that were imported at the beginning of
our modeling file if you remember
like we had a lot of import from the the
dot model output
module so those outputs are a bit of a
hybrid between the name tuple and the
dictionary so you can access
everything either by doing dots like
this so output.legit you can also
access things by
asking with a key
ah
so outputs and then we ask for the
logits key like
it would if like a dictionary which
works as well
[Music]
um
if we just ask for the base
representation we can see that sequence
classifier outputs which contain load
sheets
and this tensor so here it contains only
one thing but most of the transformer
model can return lots of things as
outputs for instance if i added labels
here
it would return a loss we could also ask
the model to return all the hidden
states
or all the attentions results and in
which case our output
is becoming a bit crowded which is why
it's organized as this
special class that behaves like addict
unlike an interval
so those legits because those are the
names
of what we get are numbers which appear
a bit
random they don't really look like
probabilities uh and we
will need to do one last step of purpose
of post-processing as we saw in the
video
to convert them uh into probabilities
that is
apply the softmax and if we just import
from torture softmax function we play it
we can see that now we get
the exact same score that we had at the
beginning so for instance for the second
sentence
like we have at 0.99 so 99.95 percent
and if we look back at the result of the
pipeline we can see
that we had 99.945 here
so the exact same scores and
to know which which one was the negative
and which one to the positive level
the pipeline is using that field from
the model configuration
so for each model the configuration file
associated to it
is accessible via the config attribute
and the id to label field contains the
correspondence between integers
and labels so let's see if we have any
questions
first question is is there any reason to
use a standard python tokenizer
uh i work at a gaming phase so
i'm a little bit biased and i'm gonna
say no you have to
using the fast organizer is always gonna
be better so it's gonna be
even if you don't have many many texts
it's going to be
at the same speed at the very minimum or
maybe faster than the python tokenizer
standard python tokenizer
but also it has many more features so
we'll look at them in the second part of
the course mainly
but it has features that have been
designed specifically for tasks like
like um token classification or question
answering
that allow you to know for instance if
from which for the token
comes from or to exactly each
which kind of text both tokens are
represent in the original
text which is features that are a little
bit uh
not a little bit way harder to be able
to get with the slot organizer
um another question is um
are there any similar tutorials or
resources for sentiment analysis for
multi-label data or regression tasks for
sequences
not right now which that's a very good
question
so not right now and we should
definitely work on that
so the main thing you would have to
change is the post processing
at the end instead of playing soft max
you would apply for
regression you wouldn't apply anything i
guess and then for
a multi-label so multiple label multiple
possible labels
for each of your sentence you would
apply probably a stimulate
to your result
and then last question is the first two
input ids the two lines are the same but
the words are not why is that
so we have to look back at the decoding
because
the two words are indeed the same so
the sentence here begins with
101 and 101 which is the idea of that
cls token
so that's why you have the first two
input ids uh that are the same
and then the 1045 correspond to the i
because the two sentences
begin with i and then it starts being
different
because you have the the r8 for the two
two sentences and another question would
it be possible to do a video explaining
the code structure the library and the
id behind it
so that's to make me to maybe make it
easier to contribute
very very good question and it's
actually scheduled for the last part
of the course uh in the part 3 of the
course we have a chapter that's going to
be dedicated to how to contribute to the
aging face libraries in particular the
transformers library
and then we'll have videos explaining
the constructor of all the libraries
of the interface ecosystem
[Music]
again don't hesitate to ask any
questions i'm going to pause regularly
to answer them
so that's uh pretty much
everything that was behind the pipeline
and we've seen it in detail in the code
so now let's have a look at the main
object inside the pipeline which is a
model
um so again we have a short video that
can which i'm going to show
from my computer and then we'll look at
the code in detail and if you have
questions i can answer them and live
code with you
let me just grab the video
which of course i can't find easily
otherwise that would be too easy
why did it disappear
and almost there i promise i just moved
it
recently
[Music]
and
how to instantiate a transformers model
in this video we'll look at how we can
create and use the model from the
transformers library
as we've seen before the auto model
class allows you to instantiate a
pre-trained model
from any checkpoint on the interface up
it will pick the right model class from
the library to instantiate the proper
architecture
and load the weights of the pre-trained
model inside as we can see
when given a bird checkpoint we end up
with a bird model
and similarly for gpd2 or part
behind the scenes this api can take the
name of a checkpoint on the hub
in which case it will download and cache
the configuration file
as well as the model waits file you can
also specify the path
to a local folder that contains a valid
configuration file
and a modal waste file to instantiate
the retrained model
the auto model api will first open the
configuration file
to look at the configuration class that
should be used
the configuration class depends on the
type of the model
bert gpt2 or part for instance
once it has a proper configuration class
it can instantiate that configuration
which is a blueprint to know how to
create the model
it also uses this configuration class to
find the proper model class
which is then combined with the loaded
configuration to load the model
this model is not yet a pre-trained
model as it has just been initialized
with random weights
the last step is to load the width from
the model file
inside this model to easily load the
configuration of a model from any
checkpoint or folder containing the
configuration file
we can use the auto config class
like the auto model class it will pick
the right configuration class
from the library we can also use a
specific class corresponding to a
checkpoint
but we'll need to change the code each
time we want to try a different model
architecture
as we said before the configuration of a
model is a blueprint
that contains all the information
necessary to create the model
architecture
for instance the birth model associated
with the pert base
case checkpoint has 12 layers a hidden
side of 768 and a vocabulary size of
28996
once we add the configuration we can
create a model that has the same
architecture as our checkpoint
but is randomly initialized we can then
training from scratch like any by torch
model
we can also change any part of the
configuration by using keyword arguments
the second snippet of code instantiates
a randomly initialized birth model with
10 layers
instead of 12. saving a model once it's
trained or fine-tuned is very easy
we just have to use the safe retrain
method
here the model will be saved in a folder
named my belt model
inside the current working directory
such a model can then be reloaded
using the from pretrained method to
learn how to easily upload this model to
the lab
check out the push to up video
okay um so let's see if we have any
questions
not just yet don't hesitate to ask any
question in the chat and i'll answer
them
regularly and for this let's
open the collab
and look a little bit at the code behind
the auto model api
and in particular we'll see for instance
i told you a little bit earlier that
our model could return more than just
delegates and it could return for
instance all the
hidden states or things like that and
we'll see how to do that
just here yes
[Music]
so if you had any questions now would be
an idiot time because i didn't execute
this notebook in advance so we need to
wait
for it to install everything
okay that didn't take so long um
so to create a random model that looks
exactly like the birth model
uh we can just instantiate the default
configuration
and use that configuration inside the
model
like we saw in the video the config
contains lots of fields that are related
to what's happening inside the model so
for instance we have the hidden size
configured
we have the number of words that our
model can taken
we have the vocabulary size
the modal type which is birth the
activation it's used which is kilo etc
um so that model
uh using just random which is just the
config
is going to be randomly initialized and
there is nothing to download there
if we want to use
a pre-trained model we have to use the
from betrayal method which is going to
download
the exact config and then the model
awaits and as we saw in the video
it's gonna use the config to first
instantiate a randomly initialized model
and then load the weights from that
checkpoint
inside the model we have and
if we want to change
anything in a model
more specifically in its configuration
we can say it in several places
so for instance we can start with
[Music]
a config that is exactly like bert
[Music]
so con autoconfig.from pre-trained
purpose case
which is gonna download and it's already
downloaded from here
oh what do you mean the two config is
not defined oh yeah i've only used bird
config so
let's continue with that
[Music]
so that conflict from pretend which is
going to reuse the config that was
downloaded here
so this is the configuration of the pert
model and if we want to change anything
inside it
uh we've seen this video for instance
how to change the number of hidden
layers
but let's say that
i want to change the fact that i want
my model to return all the
hidden states which i would say with
output in states equal to
so i can do this in the config and then
instantiate my model with model equal
birth model config i can also
directly change this when i do
bert model dot from pre-trained here
[Music]
so since if if i were to change here the
number of hidden layers it wouldn't work
anymore the command would fail because i
would i
would then try to load a checkpoint that
has been defined with 12 layers inside
the model with 10 layers
so by a torch would complete i mean it
would
it would probably work but i would have
a warning with like the weights not
being used and the model would probably
not
get super useful results but for
something like outputted and states
which doesn't really change
the the way the model was pre-trained
this is going to work
super nicely and if i try
to take inputs
so let's define some random inputs and
then pass it
to a tokenizer so i'll have to
[Music]
use the pert tokenizer and then
instantiate it with the from pre-trained
method
oh yes it's finding it here should have
executed the cell
already or
[Music]
so if i'm creating a tokenizer like this
and then applying it
to my inputs
[Music]
return a tensor i don't need to put the
padding and location that we saw before
because there is only one sentence
we'll see why a little bit earlier so
once i have done that
i can look at my outputs
and it should have
now two keys uh still one key
yeah with a little bit more because
the bird model has a polar output you
know on top of the luggage
but uh oh and it's not luggage anymore
sorry it's last hidden state because
this is not the classification model
it's a base model i used birth model
which is the same as using auto model
not a part model for second
classification so i get a last in
states uh instead of lock key the puller
output is specific to board
so it has it's all it always has that
and then i can see i have a last key
with hidden states
and a list of all the transforms which
correspond to all the hidden states of
my model
so this is how you change the
configuration of your model on the fly
either inside the when you create the
config
if you are trying to initialize a
randomly initialized model
or to the front pre-trained method if
you are trying uh to use
a pre-trained model in particular if you
are using a
classification model for instance a
sequence specification models you can
specify the most
important argument it's going to be new
labels
because if when you add your
classification add you want to control
how many outputs that classification
head has
so you would do that with the new labels
argument
um so that model and then
once you finish training or fire tuning
your model you can use safepretrain to
save it
on the floor on your on your hard drive
and you can use push web which we just
released today actually
uh so on your model to directly upload
your model on the rigging facehub so
that anyone in the world can use it
i don't see any questions again don't
hesitate to ask any questions i'm gonna
answer
them regularly and so this is
all we have to this is all we there was
in the section for models
and then let's look at the tokenizer
which is responsible for
preprocessing the input i'm going to
move myself oh not the screen
come back i'm going to move myself
back on the left because
and we we look at this section here and
look at the code inside the collab
[Music]
um
so tokenizer
[Music]
um oh yeah let's look at the video with
tokenizer's overview first and then i'll
comment everything that's happening in
this section
so tokenizer introduction
video
in the next few videos we'll take a look
at the tokenizers
in natural language processing most of
the data that we handle
consists of raw text however machine
learning models cannot read or
understand text in its raw form
they can only work with numbers so the
tokenizer's objective
will be to translate the text into
numbers
there are several possible approaches to
this conversion and the objective is to
find the most meaningful representation
we'll take a look at three distinct
tokenization algorithms
we compare them one to one so we
recommend you take a look at the videos
in the following order
first word based followed by character
based and finally
so board paste
[Music]
so we won't look at the video actually
we're going to look directly at the text
inside the inside of the
the course and our comment because we
won't have time to watch
all those videos in the slot we have um
so word-based tokenizers uh so you can
look at the video in your free time but
we're going to explain it a little bit
more in depth about
what's i'm able to do but the words
based organizer it's just going to split
your sentence by word so the easiest way
to do that is to take all the spaces and
then split your
your text on those spaces uh more
advanced would be to include some rules
to split and punctuation so for instance
the exclamation mark separated from
tokenization
or here let's split it between let and
uh
above s so we can see this on this
example with jim henson was a puppeter
uh which is separated into five words
here
so the word organizers are
were used a lot before transformers
mostly
the advantage is that
you split naturally your text onto the
spaces and punctuation
the disadvantage is that you end up with
pretty large vocabularies because they
have lot there are lots of different
words
in english and every time someone makes
a typo in some world you end up with a
new
within a very new world in your
vocabulary
so each word gets assigned an id
starting from zero going up to the size
of vocabulary
and then since we can't guarantee that
the user is never going to make a tape
or anything
there are there's a special rule uh if
we encounter a token that's not that
doesn't exist in the vocabulary it's
usually
replaced by something called the unknown
token
which is usually something that looks
like that
and between brackets
so this is uh one of those one of the
other drawbacks of the
of the world-based tokenizer so the
first one is that they have very large
vocabularies the second one is that they
need to learn that the word dog and the
word dogs
are very similar they won't know that
from scratch because when the model is
initialized randomly
it's going to have a set of a meaning
for that word dogs and another one for
that word dogs
and he's going to need to learn by
seeing lots and lots of data that those
two words
look a bit a bit alike and the last
disadvantage is that untoken
so every word that's a typo is going to
end up like this and the model can't
really
learn any representation of that it's
going to
just it's it's as if you had just
deleted the word in the sentence
so another way is to just split
your text on all characters so which is
what character based organizers do in
this case your vocabulary is not going
to be very large
because there are 256 ascii characters
for instance
a little bit more if you take the wall
unique thing but
you're not going to end up with models
that have a vocabulary size of i don't
know
300 000 or something like that
so this is better for the vocabulary
size
you probably won't get a known token
because you all see all the
all the different characters possible
but
the drawback is that now the
representation is based on character
so uh the model has to learn that for
instance the letter e
uh is not uh does not mean the same
thing when it's between an
l and a t uh where there were compared
to the letter
he here with the k and inside the word
organization
so is a representation of each letter is
less meaningful that's what
i'm trying to say and
compared to what we had with words the
other drawback is that
we end up with very long sentences for
instance for let's do tokenization if we
look
back with to our word-based organization
it will split into five words with the
tokenization with the character-based
organization
it splits in much more concurrent here
but it's
in between 15 and 20 let's say
so we end up with longer sentences and
our transformer models are usually
constrained by a maximum slang so for
instance the birth model
can only do a five five can only treat
512 tokens at a time
so using a character-based tokenization
algorithm
would make your the maximum sentence you
can fit the model
pretty short so that's why transformer
models
usually use a compromise between word
and character-based organization which
is subworth tokenization
so server tokenization
as the name indicates it's gonna split
your
your text into sub-worlds so it's still
split
between words but some words are cut
into for instance here
you've got let's do and then token and
ization are separated into
notice that you get this small and uh
with like the i never know to say that
in english
but that special thing between uh um
an inferior and superior sign with slash
w which means that it's the end of a
world
so token doesn't have it because that's
for
that's because we want the model to be
able to differentiate token
as a single word and token followed by
something else like tokenization
so the has the suffix that says here
it's in the other word but token
does not and so that depends on the
convention used by this organizer some
tokenizers have a thing at the beginning
of words i'm talking about the thing at
the end of words
and so this approach this approach
allows you to have a vocabulary that's
not going to be too huge
and the tokens still have some
meaningful semantic
some some semantic meaning uh
that's more meaningful than just
characters and
uh the last thing is that for words uh
based organizers
for instance doug and doug's uh were two
separate words here
doug as dogs would probably be split
into doug and ness
the same way tokenization is split
between token and ization
so it can learn that they have the same
prefix and then
as the suffix ization is going to be
used in other words like modernization
and the tokenizer can the model sorry
can then make sense of the suffixes and
learn
that they are always kind of the same
um and so in the next part of the course
uh
we'll look at uh into details the
different because there are three
different
um support organization algorithms that
are byte level
world peace and sentence piece we'll
explain exactly the difference between
them
in the next part of the course so
let's see if we have any questions
before we look at how the transfer the
tokenizer work in practice
yes i'm just gonna put myself here
properly
tokenizer pricks a sentence into tokens
but no
limitizations or stemming is performed
before
learning um
you know it's
let me double check i would say no but
you should ask the questions from more
people that are more competent than me
can answer you
because i'm not completely sure could
you provide intuition into wordpiece use
in pert and sentence piece type
tokenizers
i could but it's going to take
a bit of time so again i'm going to
redirect you on the forum where i can
take the time to properly answer you and
there is also
uh maybe lewis can share it here for his
tokenizer summary in the transformers
documentation that explains
the difference between a word piece and
sentence piece
which is using unique grumpy as the
scene and
the key differences between the two
does the w slw tag add any information
in the subwort organization so
yes as i said it's it's what allows them
all to know
the difference between a single word
like i mean between token used as a
single word
or token inside a word like tokenization
or tokenizer
and then let's see
how the tokenizer work in practice
so you can we have seen how to load the
tokenizer using the from pre-trained
method and what it returns and we'll now
quickly look at the video on the
tokenization pipeline which is going to
explain what's
happened when we feed the tokenizer
sequence like that
and how it returns those numbers
let me just grab it from my computer and
then i'll continue answering questions
the tokenizer pipeline in this video
we'll look at how tokenizer converts
vertex to numbers that a transformer
model can make sense of
like when we execute this code here is a
quick overview of what happens
inside the tokenizer object first
the text is split into tokens which are
words parts of words
or punctuation symbols then the
tokenizer adds potential special tokens
and converts each token to our unique
respective id
as defined by the tokenizer's vocabulary
as we'll see it doesn't quite happen in
this order but doing it like this
is better for understandings the first
step
is to split our input text into tokens
we use the tokenized method for this
to do that the tokenizer may first
perform some operations
like lowercasing all words then follow a
set of rules to split the result in
small chunks of text
most of the transformer models uses a
word organization algorithm
which means that one given word can be
split in several tokens
like tokenize here look at the
tokenization algorithms video linked
below for more information
the ash hash prefix we see in front of
eyes is a convention used by bird to
indicate this token
is not the beginning of the world other
tokenizers may use different convention
however
for instance albert tokenizers will add
a long underscore
in front of all the tokens that added
space before them
which is a convention shared by all
sentence-based organizers
the second step of the tokenization
pipeline is to map those tokens to their
respective ids
as defined by the vocabulary of the
tokenizer
this is why we need to download the file
when we instantiate a tokenizer with the
frompretrade method
we have to make sure we use the same
mapping as when the model was betrayed
to do this we use the convert tokens to
ids method
you may have noticed that we don't have
the exact same results as in our first
slide
or not has this looked like a list of
random numbers anyway in which case
allow me to refresh from memory
where the number at the beginning and
another at the end but are missing
those are the special tokens the special
tokens are added by the proper formula
method
which knows the indices of a token in
the vocabulary and just adds the proper
numbers
in the input ids list you can look at
the special tokens and more generally at
how the tokenizer has changed your text
by using the decode method and the
output of the tokenizer object
as for the prefix for beginning of words
part of words
both special tokens vary depending on
which organizer you are using
the belt tokenizer uses cls and set but
the robot
tokenizer uses html like on course
s and slash s now that you know how the
tokenizer works you can forget all those
intermediate methods
and only remember that you just have to
call it on your input texts
the output of the tokenizer don't just
contain the input id however
to learn what the attention mask is
check out the batch input together video
to learn about docker type ids look at
the processors and statements this video
so we have one questions that's linked
to what we were seeing just before the
video
are token slash w and token going to
have separate representation ids
and yes they are going to have a
separate representation ids because they
are not the same token
uh which is the the whole
meaning of that slash w token
not token sorry suffix
so tokenizer is a tokenization pipeline
i'm not going to live code
those intermediate method because you
shouldn't really learn them
we're just showing them to show you the
steps inside the pipeline
and the main thing to remember is that
you just have to call your tokenizer on
your input
like this because this is the main api
that's the most useful
and now we'll look at uh what the
attention mask is and what padding
and truncation means the the arguments
that we had at the very beginning
uh so that we fully explain what's
happening inside
all the tokenizer
oh another question is there a reason
you would save a
train tokenizer oven but to just have a
local copy
um very good question so
yeah there is no real reason to save
your patreon organizer if you don't need
to
if you didn't make any change inside it
and you always
you would always have a local copy
because autotokenizer.frompretrained is
going to cache the files
to avoid you downloading them again so
there is no reason to save it
the one exception is when you are
creating
a folder that you want to push to the
model hub
in which case you you should save your
tokenizer inside that folder so that
when you push to reserve you push your
model the configuration and the
tokenizer
that's used with it and with all those
three things uh
the you the the
face website is going to be able to
apply the inference api in your model
and you will be able to play with the
widget
online although other than that
you won't really need to use the safe
pre-trained metadata
on the tokenizer it's mostly for the
model that's going to be super useful
or and we will see in part two of the
course to do that if you're training a
tokenizer from scratch because you're
pre-training a model for instance in a
new language
then you'll need to use the safe retrain
method to save the results of your
tokenizer
so we're going to watch the last video
for today live session
about batching inputs together and then
we'll look
more closely at the code together
let me just launch the collab first
so that we don't have to wait after the
video
and then we'll watch a video together
come on
yes i want to run it and
let me grab the video patching inputs
together
[Music]
how to batch inputs together in this
video
we'll see how to batch input sequences
together
in general the sentences we want to pass
through our model
won't all have the same lengths here
we are using the model we saw in the
sentiment analysis pipeline
and want to classify two sentences when
tokenizing them
and mapping each token to its
corresponding input ids
we get two lists of different lengths
trying to create a tensor or numpy array
from those two lists
will result in an error because all
arrays and answers should be rectangular
one way to overcome this limit is to
make the second sentence the same length
as the first
by adding a special token as many times
as necessary
another way would be to truncate the
first sequence to the length of the
second
but we would then lose a lot of
information that might be necessary to
properly classify the sentence
in general we only truncate sentences
when they are longer than the maximum
length the model can handle
the value used to pad the second
sentence should not be picked randomly
the model has been retrained with a
certain padding id which you can find in
tokenizer.pat doconate
now that we have added our sentences we
can make a batch with them
if we pass the two sentences to the
mould separately
and patched together however we notice
that we don't get the same results
for the sentence that is padded here the
second one
hm is that a bug in the transformers
library no
if you remember the transformers will
all make easy use of attention layers
this should not come as a total surprise
when computing the contextual
representation of each token
the attention layers look at all the
other words in the sentence
if you have just the sentence or the
sentence with several paddling tokens
added
is surgical we don't get the same values
to get the same results with or without
padding we need to indicate to the
attention layers
that we should ignore those padding
tokens this is done by creating an
attention mask
a tonsil with the same shape as the
input ids with zeros
and ones once indicate the tokens the
attention layers should consider in the
context
and zeroes the tokens we should ignore
now passing this attention mask along
with the input id
will give us the same results as when we
send the two sentences individually to
the model
this is all done behind the scenes by
the tokenizer when you apply it to
several sentences
with the flag padding equal to it will
apply the padding with the proper value
to the smaller sentences and create the
appropriate attention mask
so let's look at the same thing
in collab unless there are any questions
no i don't see any new questions don't
hesitate to ask your questions in the
chat again
and uh let's look at the same code that
we had
to uh look again at what the padding and
attention mask
are exactly so as we saw in the video if
we try to
apply our model
directly oh no it's not exact same thing
as in the video
if we try to apply our model directly on
just one sentence uh that
we tokenize and convert it to ids like
that uh using the
same code as in the previous video it's
gonna fail because the model wants
batches of input so it wants um
it's actually the tokenizer even if you
have just one sentence
is like is adding uh one dimension you
can see like there are two pairs of
brackets
surrounding that so here this is a
tensor of shape one by i guess 16.
and so if you want uh to pass just
one sentence that you processed manually
to a model you have to add
one dimension for instance by adding a
pair of brackets here
this is for a separate example
so now looking at two
sentences together so if we have two
lists so let's say we have
both ids and both ids and we want to
make a pair of sentences
we can't we can create a list of lists
like that but we can't create an array
with the two of them because of and
don't have the same shape
so we need to add a padding index so we
could either hide it
at the handle at the beginning most of
the transformers model expect
the padding to be applied on the right
with the exception of
excel net which expects it at the
beginning
but the tokenizer should be responsible
to apply the padding because the
tokenizer knows what the model wants and
it's going to apply it
on the right side
so once you have those batch ids you can
create
you can sorry create done source from
them and then pass them through the
model
and if we look like with we've just done
in the video
at the outputs if we pass the sentences
separately so we still have to add
a pair of brackets if we want the model
to be applied on them because the model
expects
a batch so the batch can have just one
thing inside it but it needs to be
something that has two dimension
so if you pass sequence one and sequence
two we get first results
and if we pass the patch or with the two
sentences
we get the same result for the first
sentence but
a different result for the second
sentence we can see that was to our
difference here
which is because uh this so the second
sentence with the padding token
if we don't do anything special as the
model is not gonna compute the same
results
it's not gonna properly ignore the
padding token
so that's as we saw in the video is
because of the attention layers
the attention layers are the cause of
transformers model
and they are the we explained that at
length during chapter one
there are layers that not a computer
representation
just of one word but one word within its
context
because transformer models were designed
for translation at the very beginning
and if we want to translate the word uh
we don't
just need to pay attention to that word
but to also the words around it for
instance to know which gender the word
had
if it's a singular or parole noun
things like that and so if we don't say
to
the if we don't tell the attention layer
that this
is not a real token it's just a fake
token we needed to add
to have a rectangle and make a batch the
attention layer is going to pay
attention to that token and compute a
contextual representation
that has that token into account so to
tell the attention layer now that's not
a real token don't pay attention to it
we have to create what is called an
attention mask so here
we put once where we want the attention
layer to pay attention
and zero while we want the attention to
ignore so we it has ex is the same shape
as the batch ids that we are using
and the zero is put where we have the
tokenizer that bad token id
and if we do that and pass those through
the model
now we see that we get the same output
so here the first one does is still the
same
because it was not padding but this
output here is the same as this
output here which was the output of the
model with
the second sentence so this is
uh what's done uh by the tokenizer uh
if we if you remember when we were
passing our two sentences
it was returning something with two keys
one was the input ids which correspond
to
this thing here and the other one was
the attention mask which corresponds to
this thing here
um the truncation argument so when we we
passed
the two sentences to our tokenizer at
the beginning we said padding equal to
and the
truncation equal to the truncation equal
through uh
is gonna truncate very very long
sentences because for its birth model
for instance can only end all
sequences that have a length of 512
maximum
so if we have a sequence that's longer
than that uh
the model is going to fail and we need
to truncate it
you shouldn't truncate your inputs
for any other reason than making them
shorter than the maximum length of the
model can handle
otherwise because when you truncate
sorry you you remove
information so for padding we are adding
something and we can tell the attention
layer to
to ignore it so at the end we get the
exact same results with
without padding but with truncation
you're ignoring information that you
just can't recover so you will never be
able to get the same results with or
without truncation
but sadly it's needed because
transformers have a maximum length so if
you have very long inputs that are
greater than that than that maximum
length
i need to locate them and if we go back
looking at the course in the putting
all putting it all together section
we have the various uh padding and
truncation strategy
so here uh
so if we go back with two the two
sentences we are using at the very
beginning of this live session
and pass them we can pass them to the
tokenizer which is kind of then output
list of lists
but we won't be able to patch them
together without applying padding
so we have various strategies to apply
padding when we do padding a roll
through it's the same as doing
padding equal longest which is going to
pad the sequences up to the maximum
length inside the samples that you're
passing
so here we have two sequences uh with
padding equal longest it's going to pad
the second sentences the second sentence
here to the long
length of the longer sentence if we go
back to the notebook behind pipeline
we can see that here
with all those zeros being added
so that the second sentence inside the
batch is the exact same length at the
first
uh you can also say padding equal max
length max lengths refer to the modal
max length
uh so for instance it's 512 for bert or
distilbert
so this is gonna pad every sentence to
512
the maximum length of the model that
option
should not be considered when
when you have short sentences for
instance it's
in general it's better to pat to the
longest thing you have
unless you need to use fixed shaped for
some reason for instance tpus
like fixed shapes better in which case
you would use the max length option and
which is a bit inefficient but for
instance with the tpu accelerator
it's the only way to get some real speed
because they need
all the inputs to have the exact same
shape
and you can also specify a max length
that you want so for instance if you
know that in your data set
all your sentences are shorter than 128
you could say padding world max length
maximally
128 and so
you should also use truncation as we
said because you need to truncate
when your inputs when you they are
longer than the maximum
length a model can handle you can also
specify the maximum length to which you
want to truncate your inputs
so that's it for padding and truncation
do you have any questions
no questions small links shared by
lyrics
so
the last thing is as we saw before you
can tell your tokenizer to return by
torsten sort and so flute answer on
empires
and as we saw in one of the videos uh
the tokenizer as a tokenizer pipeline
video specifically
the tokenizer adds as a special token at
the beginning and at the end
of our of our sentence so it depends
exactly on which model you're using but
the tokenizer will all know
what tokens special tokens the model
expects and we'll put them
at the beginning and at the end of your
sentences
and so to to conclude this chapter here
is the wall code
uh it's just missing the post processing
but here is the wall code
that was executed behind the behind the
scene by the pipeline
um so you import auto tokenizer on auto
model for sequence classification
the auto beam meaning that you can use
any checkpoint from the hub it's going
to pick the right architecture for you
the checkpoint that was used by the
pipeline is this one you can use any
other choke point on the model hub that
correspond to a sentiment analysis
task we can load the tokenizer with the
front retrain method we can load our
model with the front betraying method
and
if we have two sentences we can tokenize
them together with padding equal true
truncation equal true return turn source
equal by torch if we're using by torch
tensorflow using tensorflow
and then we pass those tokens to the
model and to get
the post process results it's just
missing the soft max here
to have the exact same result as
pipeline
one last question i'm confused between
padding you call longest and dynamic
padding
is it similar yes it's very very similar
we'll look at dynamic padding in the
next chapter when doing training
but for those who don't know what it is
dynamic padding is um
when you when you go through your
training data and build batches dynamic
padding means
each time you have to build a batch you
pad your sentences to the maximum length
inside the batch
and so that's what padding equal longest
will do
if you pass your sentences
a small batch of sentences is going to
create a batch
with for instance eight sentences
and the second dimension is going to be
the maximum length inside
that batch whereas binding equal max
length
is going to pad everything to a fixed to
a fixed max length however the maximum
length the model can handle or the
maximum length
you passed along to the tokenizer
and so that's it for the basic use of
models and tokenizers
thank you for following the live stream
so now that we have seen that
that chapter together you should be able
to complete the questionnaire at the end
and then before going to chapter three
it's useful if you get to try to run
again the pipeline
collab that we saw together on the
batching input together
collab but we looked at together and
tried to understand
what every cell is doing and maybe even
try to redo it yourself
and then try to think of a problem you
want to welcome
a classification with a text
classification problem you want to work
on
and try to use a base model and
organizer
on that problem to be able to get
outputs
from some inputs and we'll see in the
next chapter of to actually fine tune a
model on your given problem
and in chapter four we'll see how to
upload the result to the model hub
so that you can venture that model to
with the rest of the community
and use the widgets of the inference api
online
to have demos of
of your model let me look at the
questions before we end this live stream
oh following up from the previous
question and with padding equal longest
we don't need to use the decorator with
padding
that's not entirely true and we'll see
exactly why in the next chapter we we
need to be in the dynamic of training
them all
but um if you are playing paddling world
longest
uh while you're doing tokenization on
your wall data set it's going to pad to
the longest
element in your data set so that's not
really that's not really the same thing
as doing
dynamic padding um but yeah well we'll
dive into that
uh in the next chapter otherwise thank
you all for
for following this live stream and uh
next week
on chapter three there are four
different live streams
because the chapter 3 is very different
for pi touch and tensorflow since it's
about training and fine tuning up until
now the code had some little differences
and you can see that you have a switch
here for the course if you want to
switch between python tensorflow
if you want to look at exactly those
difference but for next chapter it's
going to be very different
so you have live sessions specifically
for pytorch and have sections
specifically for tensorflow
be sure to check on the forms which one
you want to attend to and mark it into
your calendar
and yeah let's wrap this up thanks a lot
for coming
bye